en este vídeo profundizaremos un poco
más en la noción de democracia la razón
por la que será útil es porque nos
orientará acerca de las decisiones que
los padres fundadores de los estados
unidos de américa tuvieron que tomar
cuando ratificaron la constitución
estadounidense también nos va a aclarar
un poco nuestras ideas acerca del
gobierno estadounidense como lo
conocemos hoy en día y el tipo de
democracia que tiene especialmente en
sus distintos niveles la palabra
democracia proviene del griego y
significa autoridad del pueblo tenemos
se refiere al pueblo oa las personas y
gracia se refiere a gobierno entonces
democracia es el gobierno del pueblo a
grandes rasgos podemos hablar de tres
tipos generales de democracia el primero
es la democracia participativa el
segundo es la democracia pluralista y el
tercero es la democracia de élite vamos
a definir las tomando como base la
palabra participativa que crece
qué es la democracia participativa como
ya habrás imaginado implica una amplia
participación de la gente vamos a
escribir amplia participación
y cuál sería un ejemplo de democracia
participativa imaginemos un pequeño
pueblo que tiene algunos cientos o pocos
miles de habitantes si surge la cuestión
de colocar o no un semáforo en una
intersección o cambiar algunas leyes de
zonificación podemos suponer que una
gran parte de los ciudadanos se hará
presente para opinar acerca de esa
decisión ahora bien cuáles son algunas
de las ventajas y desventajas de una
democracia participativa a las ventajas
les voy a poner signos de más una de las
ventajas es que parece acercarse más a
la intención original de la democracia
proviene de la antigua grecia la antigua
atenas el lugar de nacimiento de la
democracia donde los habitantes se
reunían para debatir las cuestiones
importantes aunque incluso en la antigua
atenas había que tomar con cautela las
decisiones porque no toda la gente
participaba en su mayoría eran los
ciudadanos ricos quienes tenían tiempo
de sentarse y debatir esas cuestiones
si queremos demostrar la democracia
participativa digamos que en nuestro
pequeño pueblo está presente la
democracia participativa representando
realmente las opiniones de la gente
entonces una ventaja sería que
representa bien al pueblo la gente
participa directamente y cuáles serían
sus desventajas bueno puede volverse
difícil logísticamente en nuestro
ejemplo estamos hablando de un pueblo
pequeño pero qué sucede si es un pueblo
más grande o si nos referimos a un
estado o un país en donde estamos
hablando de decenas de miles o cientos
de miles o millones o decenas de
millones de personas cómo hacemos que
toda esta gente opine sobre una cuestión
incluso logísticamente cómo puede toda
esa gente informarse y estar preparada
para opinar sobre diversas cuestiones
por supuesto si estamos en un pueblo
pequeño podemos decidir fácilmente si
debe ponerse un semáforo en determinado
cruce pero si hablamos de asuntos de
importancia nacional
o internacional que afectan a cientos de
millones de personas podemos confiar en
que la gente esté informada acerca de
las complejidades del sistema bancario
la política militar o la política
exterior entonces aquí realmente la
pregunta es es una cuestión de escala la
historia no nos ofrece ningún buen
ejemplo de democracia participativa
donde las opiniones trasciendan
considerablemente más allá de grupos de
personas bastante reducidos por ejemplo
en eeuu la escala más grande a la que
vamos a poder ver esto es en asuntos
como las medidas sujetas a votación en
una ciudad oa nivel estatal cuando la
gente vota directamente sobre ciertas
medidas o determinadas leyes pero
incluso en esos casos se trata de un
alcance limitado para el peso que la
opinión de la gente realmente podría
tener el siguiente tipo de democracia es
la democracia pluralista el pluralismo
se refiere a la idea de muchos grupos
diferentes
es la palabra plural que significa
muchas cosas entonces tenemos muchos
grupos diferentes con intereses opuestos
que van a sostener un intenso debate
entre sí para decidir cuáles son las
mejores ideas y cuál sería un ejemplo de
democracia pluralista nuevamente si
hablamos de eeuu hay muchos grupos con
intereses diferentes podemos pensar en
los distintos cabilderos en todos los
diversos grupos que representan a varios
tipos de personas que intentan convencer
a los miembros del congreso ya sea a
nivel nacional o estatal de que sus
intereses son convenientes incluso
dentro del congreso aunque hay dos
grupos principales existen distintas
facciones que someten todo a debate pero
cuáles son las ventajas de una
democracia pluralista bueno podemos
suponer que este vigoroso debate hace
que afloren las buenas ideas vamos a
escribir afloran buenas ideas no hay un
único grupo o un pequeño grupo de
personas que dominen
ningún grupo domine pero por el otro
lado hay algunas desventajas cuáles
podrían ser tal vez tantos debates y
discusiones sean ineficientes porque
retrasan la toma de decisiones y hasta
pueden provocar que no se tome una
decisión o que se llegue a un punto
muerto porque la gente no puede ponerse
de acuerdo para poder hacer cualquier
cosa hay que complacer a demasiadas
personas cada una con sus propios
intereses entonces quizá lo que aflore
sea lo opuesto a las buenas ideas y
éstas terminen extinguiéndose porque es
muy difícil complacer a todo el mundo el
último tipo de democracia del que vamos
a hablar es la democracia de élite que
es en la que existe una participación
más limitada en cierto modo es casi lo
opuesto a la democracia participativa
aquí tenemos una participación limitada
de hecho aunque mencionamos a la antigua
atenas como un ejemplo de democracia
participativa realmente era más una
democracia de élite
en la cual la gente que tenía más tiempo
influencia y dinero era la que realmente
opinaba sobre las cuestiones
concernientes a la antigua atenas y si
hablamos de la república romana vemos
que también los senadores romanos
pertenecían a una élite entonces cuáles
piensas que son las ventajas de una
democracia de élite un beneficio podría
ser que esas élites por así decirlo
están más educadas que el público en
general y eso les permite tomar
decisiones más informadas especialmente
sobre asuntos que son tan complejos que
sería difícil para cualquier otra
persona emitir una opinión si vamos a
modificar una nueva norma contable o si
vamos a pensar en cómo regular la
industria de las telecomunicaciones o si
hablamos de alguna negociación comercial
o de política exterior muy sofisticada
esa educación o están más informado
puede ser de ayuda la democracia de
élite también puede ser más decisiva que
la democracia pluralista y la
participativa la democracia
participativa puede apelar a los
instintos más básicos a las pasiones de
la gente mientras que en la democracia
pluralista los muchos grupos que
compiten entre sí pueden no tomar una
decisión incluso aunque tenga sentido en
cambio si tenemos un grupo más pequeño y
una participación limitada las
decisiones se pueden tomar de una manera
más clara pero cuáles son las
desventajas de este tipo de democracia
bueno la desventaja más evidente es que
el concepto de élite va en contra de la
idea general de democracia puede ser que
las élites hagan un buen trabajo y
realmente representen los intereses del
pueblo pero qué pasa si solo son buenas
para representar los intereses de la
élite realmente representan al pueblo es
una democracia en la que el pueblo es
soberano y la autoridad le pertenece o
es una oligarquía en la que únicamente
un puñado de gente tiene la autoridad y
la usa a favor de sus propios intereses
después de ver este vídeo observa el
mundo que te rodea piensa en qué
elementos de democracia participativa de
democracia pluralista y de democracia de
élite hay en el país donde vives en los
siguientes vídeos veremos como esas
dimensiones de la democracia fueron
objeto de un enérgico debate por parte
de los padres fundadores de los eeuu de
américa cuando ratificaron la
constitución estadounidense hablaremos
de este debate cuando estudiemos los
documentos anti federalistas
especialmente el brutos número uno y
también cuando estudiamos los documentos
federalistas especialmente el
federalista número 10 escrito por james
madison cuando los analicemos podrás
decidir quién tenía razón y qué tipos de
democracia predominan en eeuu a
diferentes niveles nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo